the Wagner group says it stopped
recruiting mercenaries in Russia for at
least a month the Kremlin says that
won't affect operations in Ukraine and
that the compulsory recruitment of new
soldiers won't be needed Wagner leader
Evgeni pragosan agreed to a deal to move
to Belarus after launching a mutiny
against Russia's military leaders last
month
but for more on this let's speak with
Julia chapovalova she's in Moscow for us
and the Wagner group announcing they're
suspending the recruitment but what more
do we know about it and the kremlin's
reaction Julia
indeed the announcements that a Wagner
suspends the recruitment of the
masteries for a month recently appeared
in the company's telegram channel in the
job advertisement section in particular
according to the announcements the
reason to stop recruiting was due to
Wagner's temporary non-participation in
this special military operation in
Ukraine as they put it and its current
transfer to the Republic of Belarus
therefore they wrote that they were
temporarily suspending the work of
regional recruitment centers for a
period of one month but of course we'll
have to wait and see how it's going to
play out earlier president of Belarus
lukashenko confirmed that the Wagner
group would no longer be based in Russia
in some Russian cities posters with
calls to join the Wagner group were
replaced with other posters with an
invitation to sign a contract and serve
in the regular Russian army uh by the
way there were also reports that
precautions another massive asset his
media Empire is coming to an end too
precaution was building it for at least
10 years but now its websites are being
blocked and its officers are being
searched there are many reports that
employees of those media sources are
being fired now that's despite earlier
reports that probably all those people
would remain in their positions and
their news outlets would be transferred
to another owner journalists used to
call precautions media resources his
troll Factory its employees used to
write comments in support of the
authorities criticize the opposition and
promote the so-called patriotic views
also interesting that in February 2018
the U.S Department of Justice accused
precaution of interfering in the 2016
U.S presidential election and after that
this state imposed personal sanctions
against precaution so what the future
holds for precaution his Wagner group
and his media Empire including the troll
Factory we're waiting for updates to
answer those questions all right Julia
meanwhile Russia's Security Agency the
FSB has said that it's prevented an
assassination attempt of the Russian
appointment appointed head of Crimea
yeah that's right the Russian side
immediately blames the Ukrainian special
services for organizing the
assassination attempt the FSB showed a
detained Russian citizen who according
to the FSB had been recruited by the
special services of Ukraine it was said
the man was trained in mine explosive
business according to the intelligence
Services the uh he planned to blow up a
car next to Governor axionov's motorcade
Axion of thanked the FSB for preventing
the attempt saying that the only way to
completely eliminate the terrorist
threat from Kiev was to fulfill the
goals of Russia's special military
operation in Ukraine while the Kremlin
spokesman said that the head of Crimea
was a was a fighter and an assassination
attempt could not intimidate him that's
the Russian take on the events all right
Julia thank you for that that is a Julia
chapovaleva joining us from Moscow